Let's jump right into lesson one with an example.
Let's say you have a big exam tomorrow and
your memory needs to be as sharp as possible.
What would you do to prepare? Well, let's say I
asked this question to a bunch of people and
42% said they would get a good workout the
night before, 28% said they would eat a good
dinner. 16% said they would stay up studying. 13% said
they'd get a good night's sleep. And the remaining 1% said something
else. Would you believe these survey results? Before deciding whether or not you
would, what would you want to know? How many people I surveyed, who
I surveyed, or maybe, how the survey was conducted. Check all that apply.